Hello friends and family welcome to your
program well-anticipated Bible QA at
right here with your three ABN family my
name is idalia dinzi and I will be
sharing this next hour with you all with
my co-workers here men of God men of the
word men that are after God's Own height
and we are encouraged as we have these
Bible questions we cannot understand
certain texts or we have doubts and the
Lord has hand-picked our panelists for
this hour to answer some of your
questions soon I will be sharing some
information where you can send your
comments and your very own questions to
my right I have Jason Bradley Mr Bradley
welcome to the program thank you thank
you it's great to be here you know I got
some some questions that really had me
uh searching amen searching for the
answer so I really appreciate that amen
amen thank you folks now we also have
Daniel perin welcome that's right and
once again like you said I appreciate
these questions they keep me looking for
things that maybe I had not asked and
the Bible tells us God has given us
everything we need for life and
godliness so in the word we're going to
find the answer amen praise the Lord and
we have Pastor Daniel morigone welcome
thank you so much yeah there were some
good questions that people sent in so
yes yeah praying that the Lord will give
the right answer wonderful wonderful
well you know it's I I personally and
genuinely enjoy this program because
it's I can identify and a lot of the
questions that people are asking I part
of my questions as well but I want to
reflect on Matthew 4 4 with you Jesus
answered it says it is written man does
not live on bread alone but on every
word that comes from the mouth of God so
the scripture is out of the mouth of God
and in this comment I have Justice God
gave the Israelites Manna in a
supernatural way so also man must rely
on God for Spiritual feeling so we are
being fed during this hour and I want
you to know that there's no question too
simple there's no question too small
there's no question too big because what
is in your heart you we're here to help
you in your daily walk with Christ and
there shouldn't be anything between God
and us right so if we have doubts if we
have questions that's going to block our
our understanding of God's infinite in
in deep love for us so
to continue I'd like to ask Daniel
pering do you mind praying so we can get
started there are Folks at home grabbing
their Bibles in their notebooks and just
ready to receive the blessing of this
hour we pray that nothing will enter
vain or in nothing will interrupt your
commune with the Lord this hour yes
let's bow our heads dear father in
Heaven Lord we are grateful that you
sent Jesus to this earth thank you to be
our savior and that you left for us at
this uh the Bible the word of God and
you give us the Holy Spirit to help us
understand it send us your spirit today
here in this room and in each living
room each car each device wherever it
might be heard help us to understand and
apply and to love your word in Jesus
name we pray amen amen well folks you
have an opportunity to send in your
comments and your very own questions and
if you've sent in a question already
it's okay you have more questions we
welcome them so you can find us in
Instagram at 3abn underscore official
3abn underscore official you can also
text us your comments and questions at
618-228-3975 that's
1-618-228-3975 if you would like to send
an email of course you may Bible q a at
3abn.tv bible QA at
3abn.tv okay let's go to the first one
we received it from Instagram and Jason
Bradley here we go
I've heard the Jews were not supposed to
eat milk this includes dairy products
cheese Etc and meat together is this
true and are we supposed to do this as
well because it's in the same area in
the Bible where they talk about clean
and unclean Meats I've been struggling
with this a lot please pray for me
um
well I'll tell you this will definitely
pray for you I got to be 100 honest and
transparent with you I struggled with
answering this question as I was looking
things up so I've I've learned quite a
bit so thank you so much for your
question but I want to let you know that
it is true that Jews were not supposed
to eat dairy products and meat together
the laws of kosher Define which foods a
person can and cannot eat and also how
they should produce and handle certain
foods as well now in Hebrew the word
kosher means fit or proper so let's look
at a few verses and gain some clarity on
the subject Exodus chapter 23 verse 19
says the first of the first fruits of
your land you shall bring excuse me into
the house of the Lord your God you shall
not boil a young goat in its mother's
milk now from The Seventh-Day Adventist
Bible commentary
text Unearthed at Ross Shamrock I hope
I'm saying this properly
Ross Shamrock the ancient ugarit a
Syrian coastal city opposite the island
of Cyprus revealed the fact that boiling
sacrificial kids in their mother's milk
was a ritual practice of the Canaanites
it was probably to avoid this Heathen
right that God forbade his people to do
so from Jameson Fawcett Brown commentary
it says this a Prohibition against
imitating the superstitious rights of
the idolaters in Egypt who at the end of
their Harvest
seed a kid in its mother's milk and
sprinkled the broth as a magical charm
on their Gardens and Fields to render
them more productive The Following
season
so I I think we should avoid that First
Corinthians chapter 10 verse 28 and
verse 31 says but if anyone says to you
this was offered to Idols do not eat it
for the sake of the one who told you and
for conscience sake for the Earth is the
Lord's and all its fullness therefore
whether you eat or drink or whatever you
do do all to the glory of God also I'm
reminded of Daniel chapter 1 verse 8 and
it says but Daniel purposed in his heart
that he would not defile himself with
the portion of the king's Delicacies nor
with the wine which he drink therefore
he requested of the chief of the eunuchs
that he might not defile himself here's
the thing man wasn't permitted to eat
meat until after the flood and so if we
want to learn about the optimal diet for
mankind then we need to go back to the
Garden to the Garden of Eden a
plant-based diet is optim for Optimal
Health and that's the way that God had
originally designed it
amen thank you what interesting answers
and it's all biblical now it's it's
interesting English is my second
language so when I hear boiling kids
it's boiling the baby goats correct okay
yeah so I just want to clarify okay so
yeah there's a language barrier for me
anyway Daniel perin are you ready for
your first one because here it's coming
Jenny from Washington she sent in a text
for you it says in Acts 9 17
ananias laid hands on Saul and prayed
for him to be filled with the Holy
Spirit do people need other believers to
lay hands on them to be filled with the
Holy Spirit in certain situations okay
well first of all let me just say if I
lay my hands on somebody it means we're
connected we're friends we're in the
same room it's intimate it's up close
it's it's personal and it shows that we
are united in purpose and we are
together and so that's one thing we see
in the laying on of hands but let's look
at this text in Acts 9 17. it says and
ananias went his way and entered the
house and laying his hands on him he
said brother Saul the Lord Jesus who
appeared to you on the road as you came
has sent me that you may receive your
sight and be filled with the holy spirit
so in verse 11 and 12 just a little bit
earlier Paul had been in prayer and he
had in answer to his prayer had received
a vision that ananias was going to come
and lay hands on him now remember in in
this chapter Paul is blind and so when
analyze lays his hands on him it's very
reassuring and after that he was healed
by God which makes us think of Jesus
words at the very end of The Book of
Mark chapter 16 verse 17 and 18. this
says and these signs will follow those
who believe and one of them is they will
lay their hands on the sick and they
will be healed amen there's a few
examples throughout the Bible of laying
hands on people Genesis 48 14 Israel
blesses Joseph's two sons laying his
hands on them in Matthew 19 Jesus also
blesses children laying hands on them
numbers 8 verse 10 people lay their
hands people of Israel lay their hands
on the Levites to consecrate them to
Ministry numbers 27 verse 18 as Moses is
commissioning a new leader that's Joshua
he lays his hands upon him all right and
then in the New Testament Mark 6 verse 5
says this now Jesus could do no Mighty
Works in that city except that he laid
his hands on a few sick people and
healed them there's a number of texts
like this where Jesus touched laying his
hands on people heals them but Jesus
also heals we know some stories over a
long distance as well so following these
examples from the old Testament the
apostles laid their hands on those who
were dedicated to ministry as a symbol
recognizing that God had authorized them
and commissioned them to Ministry acts 6
6 is one of those I'll read it to you
this is dealing with the seven deacons
that were set apart and it says in that
text when they had prayed they laid
hands on them so notice that the laying
on of hands goes hand in hand with
prayer so we're we're inviting and
asking for God's power and you can look
at three other texts here acts 13 3 2
Timothy 1 6 and 1st Timothy 5 22 to see
three other places where leaders are
commissioned and sent out by laying on
of hands and so that commissioning
simply acknowledges the approval that
God has already placed on somebody and
this is the opposite of take pilate who
washes his hands and says I'm not
connected this is a public statement of
saying we are acknowledging and
accepting God's leadership and we're all
so then as people submitting to the
leadership of these spiritual leaders
Hebrews 13 7 and 17 says remember those
who rule over you who have spoken the
word of God to you whose Faith follow
obey those who rule over you and be
submissive for they watch out for your
souls so this laying on hands is an
acknowledgment that we are united as a
family and these are leaders that God
has chosen and we will submit to their
Authority because it comes from God
uh one other New Testament example here
in Acts 19 6 says when Paul laid hands
on them all right there's a group here
the Holy Spirit came upon them and they
spoke with tongues and prophesied so you
have the receiving of the Holy Spirit
but we also have instances where the
holy spirit is received without the
laying on of hands and so this lets us
know that the laying on of hands is an
expression of an Act of Faith in the
power of God there's no direct command
with the Great Commission to lay hands
on simply to go out and teach and
baptize but its usefulness is in what it
depicts and that is submission to
Authority respecting community and
acting in faith in God's power God Alone
is the one who gives Grace and spiritual
gifts amen praise the Lord beautiful
praise God thank you Lenny I mean uh
let's see Jenny and Jenny from
Washington sent in that text now Pastor
mariconi I'm going to go to you next and
this comes from dawn from New York
through a text she sent in the Bible
says in Genesis 1 27 so God created man
on his own image we serve a perfect
sinless God why do we as his creation
hath Wicked and sinful Hearts good
question it sure is a good question I've
wondered that myself
but let's go to that Genesis chapter 1
verse 27 yes it says that
and so God created man in his own image
of course we know that God is Holy like
you're saying
he created them in his own image male
and female he created them
and so again thank you for that question
and it's true that God created man holy
and perfect
everything that he created was perfect
and it was sinless also you know in
Ezekiel it talks about God creating this
Angel says Thou was perfect in thy ways
from the day that thou was created till
iniquity was found in thee so it wasn't
God's fault that we have what the way
we're at right now where we've come to
in Genesis chapter 3 if we turn over
there we see what happened there God
created everything perfect and then in
chapter 3 we see the serpent coming into
the garden and then
deceiving Eve
to you know he he was perfect but then
he chose to go against God and his love
for him
that's what made him imperfect so now
Adam is imperfect because of his
selfishness he chose to have Eve and not
lose Eve because he knew what was going
to be the results of Eve being taking
that fruit
so
he wasn't under the deception he chose
willfully to go against God and um
so God created man totally selfless and
other centered
with this other centered love and then
when he chose and became selfish
their Natures were actually changed now
Adam and all of us as his descendants
were all selfish we were born that way
that one sin broke the connection of
Adam with God
and that was he was his maker and a
sustainer and God's the source of
Selfless Love which I believe you know
has energy emanating from him to sustain
us to be selfless so you recall when God
called them they were hiding why were
they hiding
because they were naked they realized
that they were naked so that connection
was broken from God's glory to keep them
selfless so I believe that they had the
light of God's glory shining upon them
prior to that and remember when God
asked them about eating the fruit
what did they say they did the blame
game right she did it no it wasn't me it
was the snake
so and of course the snake didn't have a
leg to stand on
literally and then that's my
three-minute version of our Wicked
Hearts why we have them today very good
thank you so much and yes you know the
the finger pointing is consistent you
know throughout Humanity but you know we
need to point everyone to Jesus amen he
forgives us and receives us Jason
Bradley are you ready we have a text
here and it says is exercising on the
Sabbath a good thing or is that not
honoring the Lord in keeping the Sabbath
holy I do know it's good on other days
to keep our body healthy but what about
the Sabbath ah excellent question you
know exercising every single day of the
week is great now let me unpack that
because I know some of you are sitting
there at home and you're saying oh no
he's saying the exercise on the Sabbath
well okay here's here's what I mean by
that exercising every day of the week is
great working out every day of the week
is not you know even in the world when
you're training with a trainer a
physical trainer they tell you that your
muscles need to rest you need to to rest
your muscles why wouldn't you rest on
the Sabbath now when I say exercising
every day of the week it's not okay to
go to the gym and work out and you know
hit the bench or or do your crunches and
all of that stuff you know but as a
byproduct of going on a nature walk
you're getting exercise and what are you
doing you are looking at God's creation
you're marveling at God's creation and
you're going growing closer to him let's
look at Isaiah Chapter 58 verses 13 and
14 it says if you turn away your foot
from the Sabbath from doing your
pleasure on my holy day and call the
Sabbath a delight the holy day of the
Lord honorable and shall honor him not
doing your own ways nor finding your own
pleasure nor speaking your own words
then you shall delight yourself in the
Lord and I will cause you to ride on the
high hills of the earth and feed you
with the heritage of Jacob your father
the mouth of the Lord has spoken you
know we should be doing all we can to
the glory of God first Corinthians
chapter 10 verse 31 says therefore
whatever you eat or whatever you you
drink or whatever you do
do all to the glory of God first Timothy
Chapter 4 verses 7 and 8 but reject
profane and old wives fables and
exercise yourself toward godliness for
bodily exercise profits a little but
godliness is profitable for all things
having promise of the life that now is
and of that which is to come you know
some people say that sitting is the new
cancer so you need to get up and move
around now here are some things that you
can do on the Sabbath that is acceptable
like Outreach like helping people like
going to church you know as you're
walking maybe you're walking down the
aisle to kneel and go before the Lord
you're still getting exercise it's a
byproduct of exercise but you're not
working out to get the perfect body that
you desire and all of that and I'm not
like a huge fan of working out per se if
I'm being honest but um there's this guy
that he he works out and he's he's doing
this training and I think it's called
Hit high intensity interval training now
you wouldn't want to do something like
that on the Sabbath that's right so
exercising every day of the week is okay
working out every day of the week is not
very clear very good thank you so much
uh Jason we also have guys I I want to
thank Ruth from Tennessee they sent in a
text and we're going to have Daniel
Perrine attend to this question and it
says if we will have immortality when
Christ comes for us what purpose will
the Tree of Life serve would we die if
we didn't eat of it
all right Ruth before we get to the Tree
of Life in heaven let's look at the Tree
of Life In the Garden of Eden Adam and
Eve received life from eating the fruit
and that life came from the tree which
was planted and sustained by God and so
the life came from God so the Tree of
Life represents the life-giving
preserving care that Jesus himself has
for his children and by eating of that
tree Adam and Eve acknowledged and
enjoyed their dependence upon God and
came back to it day by day saying my
life comes from God alone and so access
to this tree then was conditional upon
obedience disobedience is rejecting God
and rejecting the life that he has to
offer we think of Acts 17 verse 25 that
says that he God gives to all life
breath and all things God is the only
reason that the end deluvians people
living Before the Flood their lives were
extended so many years God is the only
reason our lives are preserved God is
the sole reason that the children of
Israel were kept alive and the Manna
kept falling in their shoes and clothing
not wearing out those 40 years wandering
in the wilderness all right God is the
one who does it all now we're told in
John 6 32 that Jesus is that Bread of
Heaven he's the one who fed them he's
the one who gave them life
the other trees in the garden were good
for food and they supplied life in one
way that's physical life but God placed
Supernatural power in that one tree by
his choice Genesis 3 22 tells us that if
they ate of that tree then they would
live forever but the life-giving power
of the tree was not the fruit it was the
power of Jesus John 1 verse 4 says in
him was life and that life was the light
of all men Jesus is the life in other
words Jesus represents that tree of life
and we have to keep going back to him so
when we receive eternal life in the in
in heaven in the new Earth it will be
given to us in the same manner that Adam
and Eve received it through faith in
Jesus expressed by returning to him
constantly the point is that our
immortality in heaven doesn't come from
us it comes from dependence upon God
three texts right here first Timothy 1 7
God alone has immortality First Timothy
6 9 19 that they may lay hold of eternal
life because we don't have it we have to
lay hold of it it's in him in First
Corinthians 15 53 for this corruptable
must put on incorruption and this Mortal
must put on immortality because it
doesn't come from us and so in the new
Earth we will and in heaven and the new
Earth we will return to Jesus over and
over again new fruit every month on that
tree in other words keep coming back to
Jesus we'll be returning to him
constantly and why wouldn't we want to
return to that tree when it's given as a
blessing Revelation 2 7 to him who
overcomes I will give to eat of the tree
of life which is in the midst of the
paradise of God by not returning to the
tree we're saying I've got life in
myself and none of the saved would ever
do that so we come to Jesus now and
we're going to keep coming back forever
and ever and ever thank you Daniel thank
you for just a moment I believe that I
said that first Timothy 1 7 I meant
First Timothy 6 16 God Alone is Immortal
First Timothy
very good thank you so much now um thank
you once again and we're gonna go to the
next question and Daniel morricone
please the candy from Maryland sent an
email and she would like to have an
answer to this question Genesis 3 15
says I will put enmity between thee and
the woman and between thy seed and her
seed it shall bruise his heel I know
they got cursed Adam for sinning and he
also cursed Satan however was Eve cursed
was her punishment for sinning
childbirth childbirth is painful
but that pain is gone once the child is
born is this an example of Salvation
when we sin we are in pain but once we
repent we are overcome with joy and
happiness
wow there's a good question there candy
thank you for sending that in
let me read it again that
Genesis chapter 3 verse 15.
it says and I will put enmity between
thee and the woman and between thy seed
and her seed it shall bruise thy head
and thou shalt bruise his heel this is
the first promise of you know of a
redeemer you know Adam and Eva just
sinned and so they were pretty glum you
know what's going to happen to us right
and then Jesus or God comes there and
gives him this promise beautiful promise
yes and looking at it that word enmity
that's hard for me to say you know
I don't know those phonemes get mixed up
in my mind there but here's enmity the
definition the state of feeling or of
being actively opposed or hostile to
someone or to something so this is what
God promised
you know in talking to the serpent he's
just been cursed in verse 14. I guess I
don't know if he used to fly or what
happened but uh now he says he will be
on his belly the rest of his life so
that was a curse for the serpent the
actual physical serpent because we don't
see flying serpents or ones with legs or
anything anymore right there it used to
be but now he's doing in the spiritual
sense Satan was using the serpent so now
he's actually speaking to Satan when
he's saying this I would put enmity
between the serpent or Satan and the
woman and the woman is God's church so
God is saying that you know even though
they did this with Satan's bidding going
against God but one day he's promised
that he's going to put it so that
they're hostile against doing anything
against God
and his church or his people yes and
when we think of curses you know we
usually think of God getting mad right
or getting even or other maybe conjure
up in your mind like someone being mean
when we think of a curse so if that's
your picture of curses I want to present
a different Paradigm here God's curses
are actually in this context blessings
in Disguise and why do I say that
like I said in my previous question our
Natures are selfish and in order for God
to be able to take us to heaven
where only selfless people live he has
to remove selfishness out of our lives
so when Adam said that I want to eat
that food anyway even though God said
not to we can look at God's cursing the
ground as a spanking
from the Lord you know well correction
right yeah correction yeah some kind of
discipline you know in verse 17 of
chapter 3 God says cursed is the ground
for thy sake it's kind of like a parent
saying well this spanking is for your
good right what kid says oh yeah sure
but uh but that's what you know God's
first their ultimate and good yes that
you know we inflict punishment on
someone that we love it's not it's
uncomfortable but we do it because of
the you know long-range goal of and
God's wanting to get selfishness out of
Adam each one of us so we have this
sweat of our brow type of a thing so
when God told Eve that he would greatly
multiply her sorrow or her pain in
childbirth that must have been a
blessing also
you know I've noticed over the years
that women a lot of times they're drawn
closer to the Lord after giving birth to
a child
it could have been carefree and careless
in their life and then when they have
this child they settle down and they
become responsible and they have all
this love and nurture for this child
by the way candy I like your
illustration about childbirth being like
salvation who are going through a lot of
in our life a lot of pain and sorrow and
when G when we meet Jesus we repent and
he takes away all of our pain and sorrow
and we rejoice in our new birth and
praise the Lord please praise the Lord
for his love and his forgiveness
um we have a question here
it just does not identify if it came
through text or not but the question is
is it a sin to use hot water on Sabbath
Jason Bradley well the short answer is
no it's not a sin to use hot water on
Sabbath but let's begin by defining sin
well for that we'll look at first John
chapter 3 verse 4 and it says whosoever
committeth sin transgresseth also the
law for sin is the transgression of what
the law so what law is being referred to
in first John chapter 3 verse 4 well to
discover that let's go to Exodus chapter
20. and we'll hone in on verses 8
through 11. now this is the fourth
Commandment we'll see here remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days you
shall labor and do all your work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God in it you shall do no work you
nor your son nor your daughter nor your
male servant nor or your female servant
nor your cattle nor your stranger who is
within your gates for in six days the
Lord made the heavens and the Earth the
sea and all that is in them and rested
the seventh day therefore the Lord
blessed the Sabbath day and hallowed
hallowed it now we are to do no servile
work we are not to conduct business and
and gain profit and all of that stuff on
on Sabbath
um the Sabbath is a wonderful time of
rest and reflection and a time where we
can Marvel at God's creation reflect on
his creation and also grow in him so you
know I have to look at this question
from the standpoint of you might be in a
country or you might be somewhere where
it's quite intense to try and get hot
water you know here where we live we're
able to just turn on the faucet and hot
water will come out you know but where
you are you may have have to walk an
extended period of time miles and miles
and carry jugs and fill those jugs and
walk Miles and Miles back and then
gather sticks and and start a fire and
Kindle that fire and you know and tend
to that fire and if that is the case
then it's not good to do that on the
Sabbath you would need to do that on
Preparation day because that's that's a
lot of work in that process here we
don't have that issue we can just turn
on the hot water and it's ready to go or
if we have to heat up some water it's
just turning on the stove and it's
heating up but if you have to walk miles
and miles and you're sweating and you're
tired at the end of it and it's that
type of process then you shouldn't
use hot water on the Sabbath in that
case unless you've prepared for that on
Friday thank you thank you so much okay
for folks I would like to take this
opportunity and share the contact
information so you can send your
comments and your questions you can send
it through Instagram through ABN
underscore official
3abn underscore official and you can
send us your text from at
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 and for those
of you who prefer
um to send us an email
bibleqa at 3abn.tv bible QA at 3abn dot
TV is the email to address to send your
comments questions we continue the
program I can't believe it time is
slipping by uh Daniel perin this
question is for you could you explain
Second Kings 13 21 we believe that the
dead know nothing yet there seems to
still be power in the bones of Elisha
all right what a great little brief
three sentence two verse long story here
the bones of Elisha I'll read it to you
Second Kings 13 verses 20 and 21 then
Elisha died and they buried him and the
rating bans from Moab invaded the land
in the spring of the year so it was when
they were burying a man that suddenly
they spied a band of Raiders and they
put the man in the Tomb of Elisha and
when the man was let down and touched
the bones of Elisha he revived and stood
on his feet that's unexpected especially
if you've never read this before and
here's the context the people of Israel
are wondering and asking so where's the
god of Elisha Elisha died of a long
protracted painful illness unlike Elijah
who was translated to heaven without
seeing death and he was not miraculously
healed and now that he's gone Israel is
wondering where is God we're being
troubled again Again by the moabites
well what remained of the Prophet you
had his bones and you had his message
and his God God shows himself that even
though Elisha is God Is Gone God can
bring life God is still there and which
means that you should keep on paying
attention to the message of Elisha the
message of Elisha still has power and so
this is the confirmation that the
message of Elisha who called them to
repentance is one they should continue
to listen to by what means did was
Lazarus brought back from the dead in
John 11. it wasn't by the stone he laid
on it was by the voice of Jesus by what
means was Dorcas or Tabitha raised to
life when Peter prayed for her in Acts
9. it wasn't by Peter's power it was by
the power of God by what means did Peter
and John restore the man who's lame by
the gate beautiful there in Acts chapter
3. it says silver and gold I don't have
to give you he says but in the name of
Jesus Christ I say to you rise and walk
the Widow of zarapath zaraphat there in
First Kings 17 raised by Elijah The
shunamite Widow's son raised by Elisha
in Second Kings Four did Elijah and
Elisha have power to raise these people
no it's all the power of God Zechariah 4
verse 6 says not by might nor by power
that's human might and power but by my
spirit says the Lord of hosts and so did
Peter have the power to raise the dead
did Elijah or Elisha no Elisha has no
power to exercise here in First Kings 13
it is God who is doing the work God
alone gives life John 5 verses 28 and 29
says the hour is coming in which all who
are in the graves will hear his voice
and come forth so when you're reading
this story remember what the Bible
teaches Ecclesiastes 9 5 the living know
that they will die the dead know not
anything and Ecclesiastes 9 10 there is
no work or device or knowledge or wisdom
in the grave where you are going this is
kind of like the Tree of Life question
life comes from the fruit through the
tree that was planted by God it comes
from God life came through Elisha's
bones but a Dead Man's Bones have no
power the life came from God amen
hallelujah amen we've been to church
guys
beautiful I Delight it's a delight
really to listen to all this now we have
this next question and is going to
Daniel morricone and we're going to read
this from Tess in the Philippines she
sent an email now reading one or First
John 3 9. is it possible that we can no
longer sin if we are children of God and
is there a difference whether we are
adopted sons of God or our children of
God
can you please answer tests
well Tess thank you so much for sending
that question in
well let me go to that second part of
your question first you know in the
spiritual sense
we're all adopted and children of God
and God looks at us as his own
you know most parents they have love for
their children and it doesn't matter to
them whether they're adopted or they're
natural born
so it's really as far as if it makes any
difference it's in the child's thinking
then whether you know they feel loved or
not because in Proverbs chapter 23 verse
7 the bible says for as he thinketh in
his heart so is he so when we recognize
that we're children of God ourselves
then we are or we act accordingly so not
on God's part that there's any
difference but
so in looking this one up here I I went
ahead and looked at the SDA Bible
commentary
and
it says being born of God it's the form
of the Greek verb shows that he's
referring to those who have been born of
God and continue to be his children
he thus includes every Christian who has
not returned to the world and denied the
Lord who had redeemed him foreign
doesn't that sound appealing though that
scripture you know I'll read it right
here whosoever is born of God doth not
commit sin for his seed God's seed
remaineth in him and he cannot sin how
many of us here would be like to be that
way where you can't sin amen well it
might be a robot then right
and God didn't want robots because it's
he's born of God is the way it's text
comes across there
that would be appealing though to not be
able to sin but here's what the
Seventh-day Adventist commentary brings
out regarding not cannot sin
he's unable to go on sinning or is not
able to go on habitually sinning and
this doesn't mean that the Christian is
incapable of committing a wrong Act
if he were unable
to sin then there would be no virtue in
being without sin again it would just be
a robot so what's the virtue of you're
making you so that you can't but and
there would be no true development of
character and John already implied in
first John 2 1
let me just go there real quick first
John 2 1 it says my little children
these things right eye unto you that ye
sin not
and if any man sin we have an advocate
so he's saying that there is that
possibility so the passage means that
having been born of God and having God's
life-giving power dwelling in him he
cannot continue his old pattern of
Habitual sin and he now follows the
sinless ideals that having been planted
in his soul by his new birth
amen thank you so much now Tess thank
you for sending that email we're going
to move on to Jason Bradley he's going
to answer this following question
Bradley here it comes it says how come
it was said that a man should leave his
father and mother and cleave to his wife
Genesis 2 24 after Eve was given to Adam
if they were the first humans and their
only parents was God at that time Serita
from New York sent us a text Sarita I'm
so glad that I got this question because
I'm actually living this right now I'm
excited to share about this let's look
at the verse that you referenced Genesis
chapter 2 verse 24. it says therefore a
man shall leave his father and mother
and be joined to his wife and they shall
become one flesh now I know you're
wondering why God gave them those
instructions when they were the first
human beings on the planet but God knew
that more human beings would be on the
planet and so he set up this as the
ideal family structure marriage between
a man and a woman and um and the man
needs to leave and cleave Genesis
chapter 1 verses 27 and 28 says so God
created man in his own image in the
image of God he created him male and
female he created them then God blessed
them and God said to them and be
fruitful and multiply fill the Earth and
subdue it have dominion over the fish of
the sea over the birds of the air and
over every living thing that moves on
the earth so I recently got married and
leaving and cleaving is this new thing
that I'm I'm navigating right and uh
basically it doesn't mean that I am to
forget about my parents all together and
say oh it was nice knowing you or
anything like that you know I happen to
love honor and respect and my wife she
loves honors and respects her parents
and and we do the same with our in-laws
you know they they've been so receptive
on both sides and so we we love honor
and respect them so that leave and
cleave simply means that
as a man I need to make sure that my
wife is my priority you know we decide
we determine how we operate and how we
run our household there is no running to
Mama there is no running to Daddy you
know to to get that you know oh we're
going through this and going through
that no that we need to have that
discussion together as a married couple
now there's nothing wrong with going to
get counseling that's certainly great
but but not running you know you have to
leave and cleave and so that's that's
what we we do now another very important
passage to consider when thinking about
marriage is Ephesians chapter 5 verses
22-25 and 28-29 it says wives submit to
your own husbands as to the Lord for the
husband is head of the wife as also
Christ is head of the church and he is
the savior of the body now some guys
would love for it to stop right there
but in verse we'll go on verse 24
therefore just as the church is subject
to Christ so let the wives be to their
own husbands and everything guys you're
saying oh yeah husbands love your wives
just as Christ also loved the church and
gave himself for her so husbands also so
husbands ought to love their own wives
as their own bodies he who loves his
wife loves himself for no one ever hated
his own flesh but nourishes and
cherishes it just as the Lord does the
church to sum it all up we need to get
back to the Garden of Eden God's ideal
for mankind marriage between a man and a
woman leaving and cleaving and growing
in him amen beautiful Mr Bradley Mrs
Bradley is very happy
Praise Jesus okay Daniel perin make for
from California he sent in a text and he
says what is the significance of Mark 14
51 and 52 why was this story placed here
okay in Mark chapter 14 Jesus has just
celebrated the last supper with his
disciples and in verse 27 to 31 he tells
them you will all stumble away and
depart from me I will strike the
shepherd and the Sheep will be scattered
and Peter says I would never depart from
you Jesus says you'll deny me three
times before the sun rises and then
Peter says I would die with you I would
not deny you Peter then falls asleep
along with other disciples while Jesus
is in prayer and Jesus is abandoned and
then when Jesus is arrested we come to
this very personal detail that you
referred to Mark 14 51-52 now a certain
young man followed him having a linen
cloth thrown around his naked body and
the young man and the young men that's
the soldiers laid hold of him and he
left the linen cloth and fled from them
naked this is the middle of the night
you have a young man who believes in
Jesus either he counted himself among
Jesus his followers and he's there in
the garden sleeping nearby or he heard
the sound or heard news and he comes
running and he's simply wearing what he
had on his pajamas in the confusion uh
the disciples are running thinking
they're going to be rounded up remember
this young man is there by choice
demonstrating his loyalty and boldness
and a hand gets laid upon him and not
pausing to wonder whether it's Friend or
Foe he slips out of His Garment and runs
off into the night naked and ashamed
he's run from Jesus and then stumbling
Shadow to Shadow until he can find a
friendly face this is a humiliating
story and who could possibly know the
details of this except the person To
Whom It Happened One thing we learn is
that the disciples were in real Danger
from dangerous men and if it weren't for
Jesus there in John 18 verse 8 it says
let these ones go uh that they were in
danger but second people also often
wonder why didn't Peter this very
outspoken disciple of Jesus why didn't
he write a gospel of his own and maybe
he was too busy well we know he wrote
two other letters and we also know from
first Peter 5 13 says she who is in
Babylon that symbol for Rome there those
in Rome the elect together with you
greet you as does Mark my son not a
biological son but we know that Mark
here was you know the author of this
gospel we believe was a disciple of a
close contact with Peter acts 12 verse
12 tells you that when Peter got out of
prison released by The Angel he goes to
the home where Mark lived and so Mark
here as he's writing this gospel relates
the stories that he's heard from Peter
and he adds his very personal detail
possibly now as he's just about to talk
about Peter denying Jesus he talks about
himself denying Jesus we can't confirm
this necessarily but this is a graphic
illustration of what Jesus said said to
you my must Abandon All to follow me and
hear this young man abandons all to run
from Jesus and it's a warning to each of
us who think that we'll be bold and
confident that that we don't have it in
ourselves we got to put our faith in
Jesus Christ alone for the strength amen
thank you thank you for the direction
um Pastor Daniel mariglani Susan from
Alaska sent an email and asked can you
please explain John 20 23. all right
Susan thank you for sending that in all
the way from Alaska yes
so looking at verse 19 where we see
Jesus this was Jesus's day of his
resurrection actually when he's talking
to his disciples there in this we'll say
The Upper Room probably and then in
verse 22 he says he breathed on them the
Holy Ghost he says for them to re
receive the Holy Ghost and then coming
to your question here in verse 23
whosoever sinned ye remit they're
remitted unto them and whosoever sins
you retain they're retained and
if you go back to Matthew chapter 18 it
goes along with this where he's just
reiterating what he had told them in
Matthew chapter 18.
and this has to do with you know when
someone sins against you you go to your
brother privately and then if they don't
listen you go on take somebody else with
you to try to get things taken care of
then he goes to verse
17 no 18 barely I say unto you
whatsoever ye shall bind on Earth shall
be bound in heaven and whatsoever ye
shall loose on Earth shall be loosed in
heaven and again I say unto you that if
two of you shall agree on Earth as
touching anything that they shall ask it
shall be done for them of My Father
which is in heaven for where two or
three are gathered in together in my
name there I am in the midst of them so
basically he's giving authority to his
church to really you don't you don't go
to the person themselves and ask Church
wise to be forgiven because only God can
do that yes in first John 2 1 my little
children these things I write unto you
that ye sin not and if any man sin we
have an advocate with the father again
that's only Jesus Christ that will help
us save us amen we have an advocate with
the father Hallelujah well we're going
to take a break right now we will be
right back we want to hear from you
don't forget don't miss your program
Bible questions and answers we'll be
right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
thank you so much well we have our
panelists our family here Jason Bradley
Daniel Perrine and Daniel morricone
please
um let's wrap this up once and for all
all right well I just want to share
Exodus chapter 20 verse 12 and this is
the fifth commandment as I was talking
about leaving and cleaving I want I want
you to keep this in mind uh as you think
about that it says honor your father and
your mother that your days may be long
upon the land which the Lord your God is
giving you so that means don't forget
about your parents it's your
responsibility to take care of them to
honor respect them cherish them love
them and care for them amen good
reminder now I had two stories I talked
about that were very short Elisha's
bones two verses and the young man
fleeing into the night just two short
verses it's just a reminder to me that
you don't have to read enormous chapters
and Link these sections just the small
little section God God gives you wisdom
and of course I encourage you as you
open up the Bible even the smallest
little piece ask God to give you the
Holy Spirit and to instruct and
Enlighten your mind and show you not
only what it means but then how to live
because of it God's got something for
you in every part of his word amen
amen you know the scripture was about uh
have putting enmity between thee and the
woman that promise that God gave that
first promise of Jesus Christ coming
where it says going to bruise thy head
he's talking to Satan that God's going
to bruise his head a Blow To The Head is
deadly I mean you don't survive that and
Jesus of course for our sake he was
bruised by his heel he felt the pain yes
he did I just wanted amen thank you
thank you God for that sacrifice and the
gift of Salvation that is available to
each and every one of us thank you team
for this hour and for studying and
loving the Lord and thank you folks for
participating sending in your questions
and comments God bless you
[Music]
thank you
foreign